เฮ
[Música]
Boa noite a todos. É um prazer estar com
vocês novamente nessa live para os
apoiadores.
Temos muitas perguntas hoje, novos
participantes.
Vamos cumprimentar quem está ao vivo.
Boa noite, Leni. Boa noite, Rafael
Gilson.
Eu gostaria que vocês evitassem
de deixar as perguntas hoje ao vivo, tá?
Quer dizer, podem colocar mais cuidado
para não exagerar,
porque já tem umas 20 perguntas para
responder no documento, tá
bem? Sem maiores delongas, só me
confirme se o áudio tá bom.
Fernando Casteliani como sempre tá aí.
Me confirma se
tá tá legal o áudio. Tá
mesma coisa. Maria Cláudia, Eliana
Gilson, quem tá ao vivo, por favor, me
confirma.
Vamos começar aqui.
Primeira pergunta. Como tratar a doença
do Laken? Eliseu já respondeu que o
áudio tá bom. Rafael também. O Fernando
também. Legal. Obrigado pelo feedback.
O link tem mais de um leaking, tá?
Obrigado, Maria Cláudia, pelo feedback.
Vamos entender que você fez a pergunta
liquem plano, que é o mais comum, mas
tem liquem escleroso, tem outros tipos
de liquem.
Na nossa abordagem da medicina natural,
funcional, a gente tem que focar não
apenas em suprimir o sintoma, que é
lesão na pele ou mucosa, mas sim e mais
fundo e na razão e na causa e entender
porque que o sistema imune está agindo
de forma desregulada e atacando o nosso
próprio organismo. Então, o primeiro
passo que é fundamental
é a mudança na alimentação, como a gente
fala todo dia aqui,
e tirar os alimentos inflamatórios,
glúten leite derivados
e alimentos processados, refinados e
industrializados. Por quê? Porque essas
substâncias podem abrir a barreira
intestinal através da interferência no
mecanismo da tight junctions, causando
liquigante, intestino hiperpermeável.
Isso leva à absorção de proteínas
estranhas paraa corrente sanguínea do
intestino, levando autoimunidade através
do mecanismo mimetismo molecular.
Segundo ponto, além da dieta, é
importante investigar e modular os
níveis de micronutrientes.
Vitamina D é fundamental, medindo o
sangue. Ela é muito importante para
modular o sistema imune. Níveis baixos,
vitamina D vão estar relacionados
regulação do sistema.
E também zinco é muito importante, selên
muito importante, os antioxidantes como
vitamina A e vitamina E.
Então a gente tem que verificar tudo
isso, porque todos esses nutrientes são
importantes paraa saúde da pele, das
mucosas e paraa função do sistema de
defesa imune.
Muitas vezes pessoas que têm tendência à
autoimunidade, nós temos que deixar a
vitamina D em níveis mais altos do que
população geral, porque esse pessoal tem
resistência à ação da vitamina D e aí
alguns casos até fazer o protocolo de
altas doses, né, como o Dr. Cícero
Coimbra preconiza.
Estresse crônico. É um grande gatilho de
líqu. Então tem que controlar o estresse
crônico, então tem que gerenciar o
estresse fundamental,
investigar o intestino de forma mais
aprofundada, se a retirada dos alimentos
inflamatórios
não for o suficiente,
pesquisar metais pesados e poluentes
orgânicos persistentes.
E o tratamento não é apenas um creme, é
simplesmente você fazer toda essa
análise. Muitas vezes a solução do
problema tá no intestino. A partir do
momento que você corta os alimentos
inflamatórios
e a pessoa faz atividade física regular,
dorme direito e gerencia o estresse, ela
já fica muito melhor. Na alturexona de
baixa dosagem ajuda muito também. A
própria ivermectina tem sido utilizado
na forma atópica para doenças autoimunes
com bons resultados.
Vários estudos mostrando creme de
vemctina.
Vamos paraa próxima pergunta.
que eu fale sobre o Redest
Red Rice, perdão, que é um substituto aí
das estatinas para tratamento da
dislipidemias.
Vamos lá.
Existe no mercado brasileiro
o monasticos purpúrios, né, também
conhecido como red e rice, que é uma
levedura.
E tem tanto na farmácia comum como tem
na manipulação.
Então vamos falar sobre isso. Então esse
red rice é o produto da fermentação
desse fungo monascos purpúrios.
Durante essa fermentação são produzidas
substâncias monaculinas
que têm uma estrutura muito parecida com
a lovatina, que é um medicamento da
classe das estatinas.
Então, por isso que esse remédio já foi
lançado até na farmácia comum,
porque é demonstrado que o monascos
purpúrios tem a ação de reduzir o
colesterol e o colesterol total e baixar
os triglicos também.
Ele tem uma ação também de aumentar
discretamente o HD colesterol.
Vocês sabem, né, que na minha visão que
é bem alinhada com o Dr. Josef Sinatra e
os outros cardiologistas
funcionais que eu tive contato nos
Estados Unidos, nós sabemos que o grande
vilão não é o LDL colesterol, mas sim o
LDL oxidado. São as partículas pequenas
e densas de LDL que dão problema.
Então o Red Dice Rise tem uma ação de
baixar o colesterol total, o LDL
colesterol também.
Mas o foco tem que ser sempre um estilo
de vida anti-inflamatório
com a retirada dos alimentos
inflamatórios.
A pergunta foi se tem efeitos colaterais
como as estatinas. E sim, pode ter
exatamente os mesmos efeitos colaterais
porque é o mesmo mecanismo de ação que é
inibição da coenzima, desculpa, a
inibição da da via, né, do mevalonato.
Ele ele bloqueia uma enzima chamada
ah, me fugiu o nome da enzima agora. Eu
vou vou lembrar, mas é a
Pozada. tinha decorado nome enzima, me
deu um branco agora, mas enfim, ela pode
dar dores musculares, mialgias, né,
chamadas mialgias, pode dar problemas
gastrointestinais, azia, gases, pode dar
alterações nas enzimas do fígado e até
em casos graves,
embora raros, lesão muscular que é
rápido mioles e toxicidade pros ins.
Na verdade, como monúscos corpúrios, ele
é monácúrios, ele meio caro,
ultimamente, o que que eu faço? Eu não
passo esse remédio, tá? Mesmo natural.
Eu passo tatina de baixa dosagem, quarto
da dose normal junto com outros
elementos naturais, tá? Eu não tenho
usado muito mais
o red e rice não.
Só para vocês saberem, deixa eu só fazer
uma busca rápida aqui que também esqueci
o nome comercial desse produto
na farmácia comum, mas eu acho aqui
rapidinho. Moná cultúrios pá.
Só para eu lembrar o nome do remédio
comercial.
Monales. Pronto. É isso mesmo. Monales,
tá? Esse que é o nome da farmácia comum.
E a via bioquímica que eles bloqueiam,
que eu não sei porque que deu branco.
Já vou responder para vocês
aí a HMG com a redutas, tá? Que faz
parte da via do mevalonato, que é
hidróximil glutaril cozima a redutase.
Essa que é a via, tá? Não sei porque que
eu esqueci isso. Bem, então hoje em dia
eu não faço isso, tá? que eu faço é
pegar rosovastatina 2,5 mg, misturar com
berberina de alta absorção,
com extrato extr est extrato bergamota e
xenicotinato. É geralmente isso que eu
faço.
Então nós sabemos que tanto as estatinas
quanto o monúsculo monasco, não sei que
tá falando monúsculos monascos
porpúrios, né, que é o redice,
eles podem bloquear a produção da coisa,
no nosso organismo, tá? Então isso dá as
dores musculares, dá fraqueza, pode dar
problema de memória. Então hoje eu já
não recomendo tanto utilizar o monales
ou monascos porúrios ou redis rice, tá?
Então eu faço combinação de de ômega-3,
berberina, extratos bergamota,
exaicotinatos noitol. OK.
Próxima pergunta. Boa noite amquinha
Maria Helena, né? Ehã.
Isso, Rafael HMB com resultados. Não sei
se você escreveu isso depois que eu
falei o antes, mas obrigado de qualquer
maneira.
O exenitol,
Fernando, ele ajuda a aumentar o HDL
colesterol. Ele tem um efeito meio
modesto de baixar LPA, tá? Não é um
efeito muito intenso nesse sentido, não.
Bem, vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Meu marido está compisóster, está
medicado em regressão. Acho prudente
tomar a vacina. Cara, isso aí é bem bem
bem espinhoso, esse assunto. Muito
polêmico. Eu vou fazer o seguinte, tá?
em respeito a vocês aqui. Eu vou dar as
duas respostas para vocês, como se eu
fosse uma pessoa com dupla
personalidade.
Eu vou dar a resposta
funcional e a resposta oficial, tá bom?
Porque esse é um assunto muito, muito
polêmico, tá?
Que que acontece? Revisando a literatura
científica,
tem evidência de que as vacinas para
ERPS, eu já falei disso em lives
anteriores, até recomendei o uso, tá?
Eh, particularmente a Xingrix, que é a
mais conhecida, Shingrix com SH e X no
final,
quanto a questão do Guilan Barret, que é
uma doença neurológica grave e muito
rara, graças a Deus, mas que teria um
risco aumentado com essa vacina para
herposter.
Então, FDA emitiu um alerta em 2021,
exigindo que a Glaxo Smith Kleine, que é
a empresa que produz o Shingrix,
incluísse um aviso em caixa preta sobre
o risco aumentado de CO de Guilan
Barrer, porque teve estudos pós
comercialização que demonstraram um
risco elevado durante os 42 dias
seguintes a vacinação. Tinha
aproximadamente três casos excedentes
por milhão de doses administradas. Ou
seja, é raro, mas estava acontecendo
três casos extras por milhão em adultos
acima de 65 anos. Então, Austrália
reportou 13 casos de
lambar após a vacinação com Xingrs até
setembro de 2024, pacientes na faixa de
60 e 80 anos.
Então é raro, mas está documentado esse
risco neurológico.
Então estudos de casos publicados em
periódicos revisado por pares, né, o
peer revealed, que são as revistas mais
confiáveis, né, do comentaram sintomas
neurológicos e músculos esqueléticos
prolongados após vacinação.
Teve um caso particularmente relevante
que envolveu uma mulher de 50 anos com
doença de crom, desenvolveu dor
articular, efusão e sintomas
neurológicos. como dormência e
formigamento logo após a primeira dose.
E os sintomas persistiram por mais de um
ano, oscilando intensidade, apesar do
tratamento com antiinflamatórios e
avaliações especializadas. E as os
exames, infelizmente, não revelaram
causas alternativas à vacina. A vacina
foi meio que isolada como a causa.
Outro caso foi documentado neuropatia
séria, progressiva, uma semana após a
vacinação, progredindo por 16 dias após
internação hospitalar, sintomas leves,
persistentes. E foi feito um tratamento
com imunoglobulina endovenosa
com melhora, mas tratamento é muito
muito caro. Isso sugeriu então um evento
adverso por causa da vacina.
Tem problemas também de adjuvantes dessa
vacina, tá? Existe um adjuvante na
Xingrix, chama-se AS01,
que tem dois imunoestimulantes potentes,
o MPL derivado do lipo polissacarídeo
bacteriano e o QS21, que é uma saponina
extraída da planta quilarra saponária.
Então, estudos demonstram que esse
sistema adjubante pode induzir uma
resposta inflamatória sistêmica intensa,
ativação de mastófitos, perdão, ativação
de monóstitos e produção elevada de
citocinas pró-inflamatórias,
particularmente fator de necrose tumoral
alfa e teleocina um.
Isso pode causar uma ativação coordenada
de células natural killers natural e
também de linfócito CD8
dos linfonóos drinantes e isso pode ter
como consequência uma produção precoce
interferongama, ou seja, pode desregular
todo o sistema imune com esse sistema aí
de adiosvantes imunoestimulantes.
Então esse componente PS21 envolve a
ativação do complexo inflamaçoma NLRP3,
que é o mecanismo tá associado a doenças
e respostas autoimunes.
Então existe toda essa questão aí,
pessoal,
de pessoas que podem desenvolver doença
autoimune com essas vacinas ou doenças
neurológicas.
É raro. Aparentemente é raro, tá?
Mas é complicado, né? Você tomar um
negócio para prevenir uma doença e ficar
todo lascado, né?
Vamos falar um pouquinho de reações
adversas comuns. Os dados clínicos
demonstram que 88% dos vacinados, tô
falando da vacina do episótera, tá?
sempre aqui que eu tô falando aqui da
vacina episósta. Então 88% dos vacinados
entre 50 e 59 anos experimentaram dor no
local da injeção. 57% dor muscular, 57%
fadiga, 51% cefaleia, 36% calafrios, 28%
febre,
24% sintomas gastrointestinais.
E essa taxa de reatividade é
consideravelmente superior ao placebo
salino, tá?
A intensidade grau três desses efeitos
foi significativa com capacidade de
prevenir atividades normais, ou seja,
atrapalhou a boa parte das pessoas. Aí
dados do Vaers, né, vocês devem me
lembrar do Vaers, que foi muito falado
durante a pandemia, né? É o sistema de
vigilância de eventos adversos à vacina
dos Estados Unidos.
Então, Vaer recebeu
entre outubro de 2017 e abril de 24
66.849
relatos de eventos adversos relacionados
a Xingrs. Não é pouca coisa, né? 67.000
praticamente.
Embora que 97,3 eram eventos
classificados como não sérios, foram
documentados 86 óbitos, ou seja, de
67.000 pessoas. morreram 86.
As causas de morte mais comuns foram
eventos cardiovasculares com 21 casos de
doença cardíaca, dois acidentes
vasculares cerebrais e acima de Guilan
Barret como causa comum da morte.
O estudo observacional também
identificou maior incidência de infarto
do miocárdio entre 43 e 84 dias após a
vacinação, embora outros estudos pós
comercialização não tenham encontrado o
risco aumentado de eventos
cardiovasculares e cérebrovasculares.
OK? Então, o que que a gente recomenda?
Eu que eu falo com os pacientes, não
tome essa vacina a não ser que você teve
dois ou mais crise de heresóstica. Essa
é minha opinião pessoal, tá?
Essa é a minha opinião pessoal.
Agora vai tomar qualquer vacina, garanta
que a tua vitamina D no sangue tá entre
50 e 80. É a melhor coisa que você pode
fazer para se proteger dos eventos,
eventos adversos, né?
Especialmente pessoas que têm doenças
autoimunes prédistências, tem que tomar
muito cuidado com vacinas aí, OK?
Porque tem o risco aumentado de
desregulação imunológica.
Teve um artigo de medicina funcional
sobre vacinas que diz que pessoas
tomaram a vacina da influenza,
pessoas com doenças autoimunes tiveram
problemas também.
Houve exacerbação dos sintomas
autoimunes.
Bem, também teve casos documentados de
erupção cutânea na pele vacina
com sintomas neurológicos que também não
tinha sido descrito anteriormente na
literatura inglesa.
teve uma documentação de um caso que
teve lupus induzido pela vacina
xingrcks.
Então é importante levar em consideração
isso, tá? Deixa eu falar um pouquinho
sobre a a visão oficial, tá?
A visão oficial, já falei aqui da visão
da da medicina funcional. Vocês já
entenderam, né, que pessoas que têm
histórico de doença autoimune não deve
mexer com isso. Obviamente, quem tem
guilambar menos ainda, né, que é uma
doença rara, neurológica,
ou que tem histórico de reações graves à
vacinas anteriores ou ainda que tem um
problema intestinal importante, uma
permeabilidade intestinal muito
comprometida.
Esse pessoal fica longe de vacinas a
princípio. Tá
bem? Agora vou falar o oficial. Com base
nas mais recentes evidências e
recomendações de importantes órgãos de
saúde nacionais e internacionais, né? Ou
seja, argumento da autoridade. A
resposta é afirmativa. É prudente e
altamente recomendável que o marido
receba a vacina contra apisóster após a
completa resolução do quadro agudo.
Vou apresentar análise oficial é
ortodoxa detalhada sobre a
justificativa.
Segundo essa literatura oficial, então a
ocorrência de um episódio de episóster
não conferiria imunidade permanente
contra futuras reativações do vírus
varicelas.
Então o sistema imune, embora tenha sido
ativado pela infecção, pode não manter
uma resposta robusta e duradora. Então,
com o passar do tempo, especialmente
para o avanço da idade
ou em condições de suporte
imunocenescência, que é o envelhecimento
sistema imune ou imunossupressão, a a
imunidade celular contra, né, o vírus da
vare celaster pode piorar aumentando o
risco de novas reativações. De novo,
minha visão é o seguinte, só tome a
vacina se tiver mais de um episódio de
erpsostra, um só eu não tomaria, tá? Eu
tomaria lisina, vitamina C em altas
doses,
eu tomaria antioxidantes, tomaria eh
imunomoduladores, mas eu não eu não
tomaria sócio se for uma crise, minha
opinião, tá?
Ã, que mais que falar sobre isso?
Bem, a visão oficial que essa vacina
seria muito importante para estimular
uma produção de células T, aquelas
mesmas que podem se desregular e dar
problema, e que essa vacinação
funcionaria como um reforço substancial
à imunidade préexistente. OK? É aquela
história, hoje em dia colou essa
conversa de que a vacina vai dar uma
imunidade mais forte do que a própria
infecção. E para mim não faz menor
sentido essa história aí que estão tão
vendendo, né?
Então mesmo a medicina ortodoxa diz que
a vacina não pode ser administrada
durante a crise, né, lógico, durante a
fase aguda, tem que aguardar a completa
resolução dos sintomas, especialmente o
desaparecimento das lesões cutâneas.
Então o CDC americano lhe recomenda que
se vacine logo que as lesões cutâneas
tiverem desaparecido.
Mas alguns imunologistas dizem que a
vacinação muito precoce poderia ocorrer
em um período onde a imunidade natural
pós infecção ainda está elevada. Então
eles recomendariam esperar mais tempo,
embora não existam dados robustos que
confirme essa preocupação.
A Socidade Brasileira de Imunizações
recomenda o intervalo de 6 meses após o
quadro agudo para a aplicação da vacina,
que isso permitiria a estabilização da
resposta imune.
E eles também falam que apesar de alguns
especialistas sugerirem a vacinação logo
após a cura das lesões, o prazo 6 meses
é uma recomendação padrão.
Bem, acho que vocês já entenderam, né?
Já me estendi demais nesse assunto aqui.
Vocês entenderam bem que eu expliquei?
Tentei ser o mais sensato possível.
Hum.
Vamos tentar manter as discussões em
torno das perguntas, tá? Que eu tô lendo
aqui.
Bem, vamos continuar.
Quais são as vacinas seguras que devemos
dar para os recém-nascidos? Só pergunta
problemática, né? Só pergunta
problemática. Isso aí que seria tão
simples de responder há 20 anos atrás,
né?
Hoje em dia tá cada vez mais difícil.
Bem, primeira coisa que eu queria dizer,
não existe uma resposta única para
todos. Cada família tem uma situação
diferente, fatores de risco distintos e
o protocolo pode ser individualizado. Tá
bem? Existe uma recomendação de fazer a
vacina de Patib logo ao nascimento.
Porém, essa é uma vacina bem controversa
nesse período neonatal,
porque a literatura funcional
integrativa questiona fortemente a
administração universal dessa vacina nas
primeiras 24 horas de vida,
especialmente quando a mãe testou
negativo paraa hepatite B durante o
pré-natal e não teria fatura de risco
familiares e além do bebê ter nascido
saudável.
Existe uma preocupação grande com o
conteúdo de alumínio dessa vacina da
hepatite B, que é o adjuvante dela, né?
Toda vacina tem adjuvante para aumentar
a resposta imune e muitas vezes para
atuar como conservantes.
Estudos recentes, incluindo aqueles
publicados 2024 e 25, demonstram que o
alumínio pode se acumular no organismo,
especialmente quando múltiplas vacinas
são administradas simultaneamente.
Isso é cada vez mais comum, né? Você
sabe que o pessoal tá tascando 300
vacinas ao mesmo tempo criança.
Nós sabemos que o sistema de excreção do
recém-nascido é imaturo.
Então existe a discussão.
A necessidade desse hepatite B é
questionável.
Se a mãe testou negativo e não há
exposição de risco, o benefício imediato
seria limitado.
A transmissão vertical de mãe para bebê
seria a principal via de contágio em
recém-nascidos.
Mas se a mãe não tem a doença, esse
risco teoricamente não existiria.
Muitos médicos na medicina funcional,
incluindo o Dr. Paul Thomas, que tem um
livro chamado Vaccine Friendly Plan, o
plano amigável de vacinas, então ele
sugere adiar essa vacina a partir de B
quando não tiver fatores de risco,
aplicando ela mais tarde entre do 6
meses de vida, se desejado,
e até questiona a real necessidade
individual.
A vitamina K nascimento, que também é
uma conduta muito comum, preveniria a
doença hemorrágica do recém-nascido, que
pode ser grave, porém existe
alternativas.
A injeção intramuscular, que é a forma
mais eficaz, tem uma taxa de proteção
superior a 100, 99,9%, quase 100%. No
entanto, alguns pais se preocupam com a
ventramuscular componentes da
formulação. Então, tem protocolos com
vitamina K oral que oferecem boa
proteção,
mas é ligeiralmente inferior à injeção.
Estudos recentes de 2024 do Japão e
Itália mostram que regimes com dosagem
semanal de vitamina K oral, 2 mg
semanalmente por 11 a 13 semanas tem uma
eficácia comparável à injeção.
e o protocolo de três doses ao
nascimento de 5 dias e um mês seria
menos eficaz.
Vamos falar do rotavírus, né? É uma
vacina oral que é administrada
geralmente aos 2 e 4 meses. É
relativamente segura e eficaz, tem 85 a
98% de proteção contra doença grave,
deve ser iniciada antes das 15 semanas
de vida.
é feita com vírus atenuoado vivo.
E o Dr. Paul Thomas, aquele mesmo médico
integrativo pediatra dos Estados Unidos,
ele propõe um calendário vacinal mais
espaçado.
Isso é bem prudente, porque hoje em dia
é muito comum uma criança tomar três,
quatro vacinas de uma vez. Então ele
sugere administrar só uma vacina
contendo alumínio por vez, espaçar as
doses para permitir melhor excreção e
menor acúmulo
e adiar vacinas não urgentes quando não
há exposição de risco, além de priorizar
vacinas baseado em risco real
individual.
Os estudos sobre acúmulo de alumínio que
foram publicados em 2019, revisados em
20242,
mostra que quando seguirmos o calendário
completo do CDC
americano, né, as crianças podem
permanecer com níveis elevados de
alumínio por períodos prolongados,
especialmente se seguirem um calendário
de catchup, que é recuperação pós
atrasos.
Então, recomendação geral para
recém-nascidos saudáveis,
vitamina K, vi oral, se preferível,
se for viável em vez da injetável.
Estão falando aqui de recém-nascidos
saudáveis, tá? Hepatite B tem que
analisar se a mãe testonegativo
é viável não administrar
ou pode ser administrado mais tarde.
Existe também a vacina trípse viral, né,
que é pertúces, né, que é o keluche,
difiteria e tétano.
A rota vírus, o pneumoco e a HIB podem
ser iniciadas aos dois meses,
preferencialmente fada, que nem eu
falei, uma vacina com alumínio por vez
quando possível. Considerar o estado
nutricional e a saúde intestinal da mãe
do bebê, que isso afeta a capacidade de
detox.
Mãe que tem hepatite B positiva tem que
vacinar sim a criança. É essencial nas
primeiras 24 horas do nascimento. Ou
crianças que têm prematuridade extrema
devem vacinar. Aí eles recomendam que
crianças com imunodeficiências, é meio
esquisito isso, mas é a recomendação,
né? Crianças com imunodeficiência também
tomem a vacina da hepatite B ou em áreas
com autoprevalência de doenças.
Certo? Vamos paraa próxima. Já fiquei
muito tempo nesse assunto aqui. Doutor,
em relação ao uso do LDN, lowo noxone
4,5. No caso de necessidade de
utilização de um analgésico como
tramalcodeína, haveria algum risco de
interação? Sim, eu falei isso na minha
aula no congresso, tá? Não pode misturar
LDN com opiácios. tem uma exceção que é
ultramal 50 mg duas vezes ao dia. Se
você tomar o opiácio junto com o LDN,
você vai ter o quê? você vai ter uma
abstinência porque ele vai bloquear o
receptor e a pessoa não vai ter o efeito
de retirar da dor do analgésico, ainda
vai ter abstinência, vai tomando muito
tempo.
Isso porque, como eu falei no curso, né,
aliás, no congresso, o RDN ele bloqueia
os setores opioides, mesmo que por pouco
tempo.
Então ele vai impedir que outras
substâncias opioides se liguem a
exceptores e assim impede ação
analgésica,
tá? Então de novo, a exceção tram em
pequenas doses, né, até 50 mg duas vezes
ao dia, mas todos os opiós opiácidos,
né, não podem ser utilizados junto com
RDN.
Aí você pode utilizar outras classes de
analgésicos não piores para controle da
dor se tiver usando o LDN
ou suspender o LDN e entrar com o
piácio, né? Que que é opácido? Fentanil,
oxicodona,
morfina. Tá bom? Esses que são os
opioides.
O senhor poderia falar sobre a baixa
concentração de enzima dal, tá? Enzima
dal é de aminoxe, é uma enzima que fica
lá na borda escova do intestino, que a
função dela é quebrar, eliminar a
estamina que vem dos alimentos que nós
comemos. É como se fosse um faxineiro ou
faxineira que limpa o excesso de
estamina antes que seja absorvida pelo
organismo. E quando uma pessoa tem uma
baixa concentração de D ou baixa
atividade dessa enzima, a estamina vai
aumentar, ela não é eliminada
corretamente, ela se acumula no
organismo e pode causar uma série de
sintomas que lembra muito alergias.
É um quadro que nós chamamos de
intolerância estamina ou estaminose.
E os sintomas são dor de cabeça,
enxaquec, orticária,
pode dar congestão nasal, pode dar
problema digestivo como diarreia,
encharo abdominal, tontura, ansiedade,
popptação, tem um monte de sintoma.
Então, as causas baixa de dal pode ser
genética, mas na maioria das vezes são
adquiridas. Você pode ter uma disbiose
intestinal, bactérias ploriferando
e que bloqueia a ação da DAL.
O super crescimento bacteriano na
inflamação da mucosa intestinal pode
atrapalhar essa enzima.
Então é muito importante ter sald
intestinal para manter os níveis de DA
adequado. Alguns medicamentos podem
bloquear também a enzima D. O álcool,
por exemplo, bloqueia.
Deficiência de nutrientes que serve como
cofatores atrapalham também no caso da
deficiência vitamina C, B6, cobre,
zinco, podem levar a baixa atividade da
enzima.
OK. Próxima pergunta,
doutor, nesse vídeo, que é um vídeo
recente que saiu aí sobre
suplementos para memória, o protocolo
seria Lions Main, Juba de Leão, né?
Exatamente. 1000 mg pela manhã e 1000 mg
no almoço. Foss patidil seria entre 10
mg no almoço, preferencialmente junto
com omega-3. Magnésio eritrionato 500 mg
à noite. PTQ 20 mg uma vez por dia,
preferencialmente com 100 mg de cozima
Q10.
É, é basicamente isso
com algumas possibilidades de ajustes.
Então, treonato é como você falou, é 500
mg à noite,
vai ajudar a dormir
e vai ajudar na memória. O lines main
também é essa situação que você falou em
1000 mg de manhã e à noite
vai estimular o fator de crescimento
neuronal, né, o NGF.
A fosfora decerina
300 mg no almoço. É isso. Pode tomar
junto com ômega-3 e junto com gordura
para aumentar absorção.
Vai ajudar a combater aquela fadiga
mental da tarde.
O PQ você pode ser
adicionado na quarta semana e essa dose
aí 20 mg pode tomar de manhã cedo e
junto com a coisa que é 10. Aí pode ser
100, 200, 300, 400 mg, vai depender
muito. Muito segura com que é 10, tá?
É muito segura, não tem problema de
aumentar a dose. Em muitos casos, quando
tem muita fadiga é melhor aumentar a
dose.
Lembrando que que ele constrói novas
mitocôndrias, ele faz biogênese
mitocondrial e a comima que é 10 é como
se fosse o combustível, tá?
Então é isso, tá confirmando aí as suas
doses, basicamente tudo isso aí que você
falou mesmo.
Doutor, até qual o valor de vitamina D
no sangue, 70 mg, 70 ng por dcl
ou valor de Pthe é considerado seguro
paciente que tem tendência de cálculos.
Aí você tem que ver muito também a
questão do cálcio na urina, como é que
tá o cálcio no sangue, como é que tá o
magnésio na urina, como é que tá o
potássio na urina, como é que tá o
citrato na urina. Não é assim uma
resposta única, não, tá?
Não tem esse valor único mágico. Eu
manteria a vitamina D entre 40 e 70 ou
40 e 80. O PTH manteria na faixa de 20 a
30.
Tá?
Mais ou menos isso.
Se a pessoa tiver um uma dieta muito
ruim, por exemplo, a vitamina D de 70
pode ser em algumas circunstâncias
prejudicial, porque essa pessoa pode ter
acúmulo de cálcio nos tecidos moles, né?
e pode também aumentar a formação de
pedra nos ins. Então, para você manter o
nível de 70 ng de dclil no vitamina D no
sangue, importante tá muito bem
hidratado e tá consumindo magnésio
citrato de uma maneira adequada.
O PTH ele sobe quando tá vitamina D tá
baixo. Então geralmente PTH alto é um
hiperparatiismo secundário, a vitamina D
baixa, mas existe também o
hiperparatiroidismo primário, então o
médico tem que avaliar isso,
OK?
Então ficar de olho, deixar PTH por
volta de 20 a 30.
Ahã. Que mais que eu vou falar sobre
isso?
Todo mundo que tiver com a vitamina D
nessa faixa da do limite superior de
normalidade, tem que avaliar o cálcio na
urina, tem que avaliar o cálcio no
sangue, tem que avaliar o PTH,
tem que avaliar a osmolaridade da urina,
a acidez da urina,
fazer um exame de urina de 24 horas, tá?
Para ver tudo isso daí.
É importante também lembrar de
suplementar K2 junto com a vitamina D
para ajudar o cálcio aí para o uso e não
ir parar nos tecidos, inclusive pros
índices, porque o K2 é o GPS, né, do do
cálcio, ajuda a direcionar ele pros
ossos e também pros dentes, né?
Beleza? O próximo.
Além dos suplementos mais comuns como
ôega-3, o biquinol, vitamina D, K2, os
vários tipos de magnésios queelados, a
cocomina complexo B prebióticos, a
outros suplementos de igual ou superior
importância para quem sofre de esclerose
sistêmica.
O tratamento comorexona é indicado em
baixa dosagem? Sim. Resposta é sim.
Ômega3 antiinflamatório ajuda na bainha
neural, na membrana neuronal. Bquinol
aumenta a produção de energia nos
neurônios. Vitamina D regula o sistema
imune. A K2 ajuda a regular também,
eu acabei de falar, o cálcio mandando
pro lugar correto. Tem efeito também de
câncer, defamatória K2.
O magnésio também é muito importante
para regular aí a esparticidade
muscular, né, dessas pessoas que têm
escarose sistêmica, cucumina como
antiinflamatório natural
e
o LDN começaria, como eu expliquei na
aula, 1,5 mg, subindo até 4,5 mg por
dia.
Outros que eu pensaria, o NAC, que é o
precursor da gluta
então vai ajudar como antioxidante
intracelular.
Na esclerose múltipla a gente tem,
desculpa, na esclerose sistêmica, a
gente tem bastante excesso oxidativo.
[Música]
Você pode estar usando também
natoquinase e serrapase, que são enzimas
proteíticas
que vão ajudar no excesso de fibrina que
acontece na esclerose.
Você pode usar o Paba, né? Paba, ele é
um produto um pouco meio pouco tolerado
assim, parte cárcere intestinal dá muito
sintoma, mas pode tentar o paba.
Ele é
uma substâncias que é semelhante às
vitaminas do complexo B.
Pode também ter esse efeito de amaciar a
pele e reduzir a fibrose.
Tem um gotucola também conhecido como
centelha asiática.
Essa planta tem uma ação de modular a
síntese de colágeno e melhorar a
microcirculação.
Pode ser utilizado também. E o LDN sim,
porque ele vai ter efeito
imunomodulador,
tá?
Como eu já expliquei.
Vamos lá. Ã, eu não gosto de ar café.
Deixo assentar no fundo. Existe algum
problema? Não, com o ar. O consumo do pó
é proal, consumo parcial é procial.
Bem, vamos lá.
O café ele é uma bebida riquíssima em
antioxidantes. Se você consumir
moderadamente, isso vai ter benefício
paraa saúde.
Quando você não colou o café,
como é o caso do café turco ou prensa
francesa,
você pode consumir uma quantidade maior
de duas substâncias chamada cafestol e
caeol.
são diterpenos, são compostos que a
literatura científica mais recente
mostra que podem aumentar os níveis de
colesterol total LDL.
Agora você sabe como eu acabei de falar
que eu não sou tão preocupado assim com
LDL,
mas 5 LDL é oxidado e as partes foram
pequenas e densas,
porém eu preciso falar aí também a visão
de outras pessoas.
A boa notícia é que, embora o café não
quadro possa levar o LDL total, alguns
estudos sugerem que os compostos
fenólicos presentes no café podem, na
verdade, aumentar a resistência do LDL
oxidação.
Então você pode ter um LDL um pouquinho
mais alto, mas não oxida.
O consumo do pó de café em si, de forma
parcial necessariamente prejudicial.
pode aumentar ingestão de fibras e
antioxidantes
e o ponto de atenção é sempre a
quantidade. Então, consumo elevado e
frequente de café não coado pode ser um
fator a ser considerado para aumento de
risco cardiovascular, se você já tiver
tendência a ter um LDL colesterol
predominantemente
oxidado ou de partículas pequenas e
densas.
Então tem a moderação com café, não
consuma mais que três xícaras grandes
por dia,
para você não ter esse problema de
excesso, né, de
dessas substâncias aí no seu organismo.
Gostaria de saber como é que a sua
prática clínica em relação à
desparatização
realmente tem uma onda aí muito grande,
muitos profissionais fazendo
disparatização
com vários protocolos super complicados
e caros, né? Podem ser naturais, mas são
protocolos assim estrambólicos, né?
No meu caso, eu sempre tomei a bendazol
uma vez por ano. Eu acho que eu ficaria
mais na sua conduta do que nessa onda aí
de disparatizar todo o custo, tá? Vou
explicar a minha visão sobre isso.
Lembrando que eu respeito outras visões,
respeito outros colegas aí que gostam de
sair caçando o parasita para todo quanto
é lado.
A minha linha de pensamento é muito
similar a outros colegas que trabalham
com medicina intestinal, né? A
gastroenterologista famosa, Dra. Denise
Carvalho, e também o caso Dr. Dr. Rud,
né? Dr. Rud também pensa da mesma
maneira.
Então, eu não sou fã desses protocolos
de paratização pontuais,
porque na minha visão
não adianta você fazer um protocolo
completo,
seja aí com 200 ervas ou com bendazol, e
uma semana depois você vai comer um
alimento aí mal higienizado, ter contato
com uma superfície contaminada e você se
reinfectar. Então, o meu ponto principal
não é matar parasita, sair dando porrada
em parasita, mas sim criar um ambiente
no seu corpo que você tenha tolerância e
tenha resistência a esses agentes,
que seja um ambiente desfavorável para
eles proliferarem, né?
é um sistema de defesa forte, uma boa
produção de ácido clorídico no estômago
e uma flora intestinal equilibrada são
mais importantes. Então tem que
preocupar com a mucosa intestinal
íntegra com uma boa digestão e uma boa
flora.
Para mim, a estratégia mais inteligente,
eficaz a longo prazo é focar no terreno
biológico.
Então, aplicar os conceitos do 5R,
remover, remover os agentes infecciosos
quando são comprovados ou remover os
alimentos que causam inflamação e
desequilíbrio a flora intestinal como
glútivados
do leite, excesso de processados
industrializados, refinados, açúcar e
carboidratos refinados.
repões digestivos quando tiver
indicação,
porque até mesmo quando aumentar acidez
do estômago, você acaba eliminando mais
ovos e lava de parasitas
antes que chegue ao intestino vivo, né?
Reino quando for necessário com
probióticos, né? E também com fibras,
né? os prebióticos para essas bactérias
crescerem numa boa,
reparar, né, com nutrientes como a
glutamina, zinco, colágeno,
como zinco carnosina,
como os derivados ali também do
gengibre,
reequilibrar o estilo de vida
controlando estresse e melhorando o
sono.
Então essa limpeza uma vez por ano ou
duas vezes por ano até são
sensatas, né? Faz sentido você fazer de
uma a duas vezes ao ano uma
disparatização. Eu geralmente oriento os
pacientes a fazerem de maneira simples
com antiparasitário e não ficar tomando
trocentas coisas,
né? Que eu acho desnecessário e caro.
Mas essa somente a minha opinião, tá?
De novo, respeito muito quem faz isso.
Eu não tô criticando ninguém que faça
disparatização, não.
O post no Instagram que eu enviei ao
grupo sobre Max Gerson alegou que
doenças são causadas por duas coisas:
tocidade e deficiência nutricional. Isso
tá parcialmente correto, né?
Na verdade, infelizmente é sempre mais
complexo que eu posso fazer.
Dr. Gesson, ele foi muito inteligente,
ele teve um raciocínio muito brilhante
pra época dele. Ele foi um homem muito à
frente ao seu tempo.
Então, realmente a gente entende que
isso daí é boa parte das doenças, né?
são geradas para essa combinação de
deficiência de micronutrientes com
ambiente tóxico.
Isso é pilares da medicina funcional. A
gente pratica isso no dia a dia.
Porém não é só isso, né? Apesar de ser
muito importante essa falta de
nutrientes e a intoxicação.
Depois de décadas de pesquisa, nós
entendemos que também, apesar da
toxicidade e deficiência serem a base,
existe outros fatores importantes. Sim,
nós sabemos, por exemplo, que a
inflamação crônica de baixo grau, que
não necessariamente é uma intoxicação,
pode ser simplesmente uma reação à
alimentação
que a pessoa come no dia a dia,
também funciona como um gatilho central
para praticamente todas as doenças. Isso
Gerson não falou, né?
Então essa informação de baixo grau tá
atrás de problemas cardíacos,
autoimunes, câncer. Ela pode ser sim
alimentada por toxinas e deficiências
nutricionais, mas também por alimentos
específicos
agressores, né, como é o caso do leite,
derivado e glúten.
Tem a questão do desequilíbrio do
microbioma intestinal que o gesto não
falou
e não tinha como saber na época dele
sobre isso.
E é muito importante pra nossa
imunidade.
Tem fatores genéticos, a gente não pode
negar isso também. Fatores genéticos
influenciam,
inclusive na questão aí do LD colesterol
oxidado, né? A questão genética pode
influenciar.
Então, Dr. Gesson tava muito correto na
sua base, mas ele não tinha como tá
acompanhando até hoje o desdobramento
científico.
Vamos lá, tem mais cinco perguntas.
Vamos ver se um pouquinho mais rápido
aqui. Ao consultar o médico do esporte
que seja funcional n esse médico
consegue fornecer uma estratégia de
alimentação, suplementação, estilo de
vida, de modo que o praticante
musculação consiga evoluir. Sim,
consegue.
Agora você tá perguntando se pode ao
mesmo tempo evitar a redução do
longevidade. Isso não tem um jeito de
medir isso aí. Eu eu tava acompanhando
mais ou menos a discussão aí que tava
tendo um grupo sobre a questão de
restrição calórica ser algo que vai
aumentar a longevidade.
Não é simples assim como eu alguém
argumentou lá no grupo.
Veja bem, eh para ter saúde aí não é uma
questão de ter só hipertrofia muscular
para ficar bonitão, tá? Não precisa
necessariamente comer cinco refeições
por dia. Você pode comer três refeições
por dia, complementar aí com uma
proteína fora desses horários das
refeições
e você vai ter saúde e não
necessariamente vai aumentar
problemas aí de redução de longevidade
por conta de tá só comendo para aumentar
a massa muscular, tá?
Então
é um equilíbrio.
Eu não ficaria passando fome, viraria um
varau só porque tem estudo em mosca da
fruta, até chipanzé mostrando que
restrição calórica aumenta o tempo de
vida. Primeiro que você não quer viver
uma vida infernal, que você não tem
prazer nenhum passar fome todo dia, né?
Não faz sentido viver 100 anos desse
jeito, né?
Segundo, se você ficar um varapau, você
vai se arrebentar quando tiver 80 anos
de idade. Não vai adiantar nada, porque
você vai ter complicações essa fratura
aí de fêmor ou de coloor ou de bacia e
não vai resolver, não vai ter tempo de
vida aumentado por conta disso.
Ninguém tem essa resposta definitiva,
essa que é a verdade. Mas sim, eu faria
uma coisa equilibrada. Eu faria
atividade física, musculação
moderada e intensa. Eu comeria três
refeições por dia com uma suplementação
com pó proteico fora dos horários de
alimentação,
mas eu não tomaria bomba nenhuma
hipótese nenhuma, tá? Porque aí sim você
tá garantindo que você vai ver menos.
Existe uma briga entre o sistema emitor
de hipertrofia e o sistema MPK, só que
ninguém sabe qual é o equilíbrio
perfeito entre um e outro.
Então, é importante além da quantidade e
regularidade dos alimentos, é a
qualidade dos alimentos. Então tem que
ser uma prioridade por uma dieta de alta
densidade nutritiva, baixo potencial
inflamatório, não precisa se tu pedir
comida o dia inteiro que se você não for
fisiculturista competindo
carne de boas procedências, cortando os
alimentos inflamatórios, gordura
saudável com abacate de oliva
e optavam carboidratos baixos índice
glicêmico, os tubérculos para você poder
ganhar massa muscular através da
ativação.
saudável do sistema da insulina.
Você pode também fazer ciclagens, né?
Você pode ter fases de superável
calórico controlado para ganhar mais
massa muscular e seguidas de fases que
você quer secar e aí você faz uma dieta
mais pobre em carboidratos
para até garantir que essas vias de
longevidade sejam ativadas.
Jeju intermitente é totalmente
compatível com isso. Você pode fazer
janela de alimentação de, aliás, janela
de jejum entre 14 e 16 horas e não
precisa fazer necessariamente tanta
refeição por dia para caso você não
queira competir, né, num
em fisiculturismo.
E você pode utilizar uma supimentação
sensata
para evitar os efeitos aí do estresse
oxidativo de uma alimentação
mais
cheia de proteína aí para ganha massa.
Aí você pode utilizar, por exemplo,
maquedese, que nós falamos aqui,
magnésio, cromo, né, para aumentar a
acessibilidade insulina também.
Então é possível você fazer uma
hipetrofia leve, moderada, que senão não
vai virar o ar no Shoegger e ao mesmo
tempo proteger a sua longevidade, tá? Só
que você não vai ficar com corpo dos
deuses, né, do do Olimpo, você vai ficar
com corpo legal, porém você vai ter uma
longevidade aumentada, tá? Agora essa
situação, quanto de estimular MPK e
quanto de estimular em TOR, ninguém sabe
ao certo qual seria esse equilíbrio, tá?
Uma
refeição bem leve, uma colher de sopa de
azeite de oliva, uma colher de óleo de
coco, protente solvido 100 ml de água,
batata doce. Com uma refeição leve como
essa, eu posso comir uma hora depois de
comer? Pode. Se não posso comer então
duas horas depois, não pode dormir uma
hora depois.
Se eu consumir o suplemento
betaína, hidrocloreto junto com essa
refeição, para acelerar a digestão, eu
posso memóora, tá? Já respondi isso
aqui, né? É, pode, não precisa nem usar
o o corridade betaína aí, não. Não tem
necessidade nenhuma, tá?
A questão é que esse óleo de coco ele é
uma uma gordura de cadeia média, né?
Porque predomina cadeia média e apesar
de ser gordura, a digestão dela ela vai
ser mais rápido uma cadeia média.
Mas por garantia, se você puder dar um
intervalo de 2 horas, é melhor ainda,
né?
Qual o melhor dentista, aliás, qual o
melhor para tratar a pneia do sono? Tô
rindo ou dentista?
Depende.
O torrino, ele vai ser mais útil quando
o problema pode poder ser resolvido com
uma prótese dentária noturna, né? Uma
plaquinha noturna. E o torrino vai ser
mais útil se a causa for mais cirúrgica,
por exemplo.
Então, o torrino vai avaliar se tem
obstruções anatômicas que podem estar
causando ou piorando a pneia.
Ele pode indicar os CPAP, mas não é o
único profissional que pode fazer isso.
Outros profissionais podem fazer também
médicos.
O dentista
ele vai mais atuar nos casos de a pnea
do obstrutiva leve, confeccionando os
aparelhos intraurais
que vão atuar reposicionando a mandíbula
e a língua pra frente, aumentando a
passagem de ar.
Então ele vai ser uma boa alternativa
para quem não vai se adaptar ao CPAP. Eu
não preciso usar o CEPAP.
Então geralmente o caminho começa com
otorrino ou com pneumologista, outro
médico que trabalha com policografia.
Esse vai fazer o diagnóstico e a partir
daí ele pode estar indicando para o
otorrino, desculpa, o
bucmaxilo, né, ou dentista que pode
fazer a prótese dentária.
Alguma forma de amenizar os efeitos
colaterantes de drogas, como carmazepina
200 e feno barabital 100 mg.
E se existe outras medicações mais
modernas
para amenizar os efeitos colaterais do
carepinobital,
nós precisamos entender quais são os
problemas que esses medicamentos mais
antigos podem
proporcionar.
Ele tem o metabolismo do fígado intenso
e esse metabolismo pode depletar, ou
seja, reduzir nutrientes essenciais.
Então eles vão aumentar a necessidade de
várias vitaminas no complexo B, como
biotina, B6,
a B12, que tem cobalamina e também o
folato.
E a falta desses minerais pode causar
cansaço, confusão mental, piorar o
humor.
Além disso, esses remédios podem
acelerar a degradação da vitamina D.
Isso é um problema. E também pode afetar
a vitamina K.
Então é isso, suplementar com bom
complexo B, suplementar vitamina D e K2.
Magnésio deve ser considerado também
porque ele ajuda na função neuromuscular
e relaxamento.
Você pode também pensar no NAC por conta
do estresse que esses medicamentos podem
causar no fígado. Mesma coisa com a
cimarina.
E tem medicamentos mais modernos, sim,
que tem um perfil de efeitos colaterais
mais seguros.
Nós temos a lamotrigina, tem o
levetracetã,
a oxbasepida,
carbasepina, desculpa. Então, derivado
da carmazepina
e o topiramato
são convivantes mais recentes e costumam
ser mais seguros.
Porém, nunca pare de tomar uma medicação
por conta própria. Faça com uma
orientação de um neurologista.
Que mais? Temos mais perguntas aqui. Me
indica o3 concentrado que o senhor usa
usaria da marca que o senhor recomenda.
Isso tá no documento, né, pessoal?
um documento lá, mas eu vou colocar aqui
na no chat, não sei nem se vai caber
aqui. Vou ver se cabe.
Acho que não vai caber,
tá? Eh, dividiu em três mensagens aqui,
ó. Depois você pausa o vídeo e vai
anotando, tá? Eu vou passar aqui, ó.
Aí colocou fora de ordem,
mas eu vou ler aqui então, tá?
Nutri wave, Equalive,
Life Extension, Omega Pure, Omegach,
Olea, Triple Strength Omega da GNC,
ômega3 TG da CTIA, ultra ômega3 nafuts,
ômega Supraak,
ôega Forus Vitaforc,
né, você falou aí, tá bom? São esses
daí.
Próxima.
Dra. Alan. Quia e novas tecnologias
teria uma maneira de procurar um sistema
específico todos os vídeos que você
disse sobre determinado assunto? Então
eu tava fazendo isso, mas tava dando um
baita de um trabalho e eu pedi para
alguns de vocês assumirem esse papel e
ninguém quis assumir porque eu tava
pegando o quê? Eu tava pegando toda
o script, né, dos vídeos e tava
transformando um documento, mas isso dá
trabalho. Aí ajuda muito, mas ainda
ainda é uma coisa manual, tá?
Então se você for ver os vídeos antigos,
a boa parte dele já tem essa marcação no
vídeo, só que isso dá trabalho, né? E eu
tava fazendo até um certo ponto. Depois
eu parei de fazer porque eu tava sem
tempo.
E assiste todas as lives, né? Eh, não
tenha preguiça, né, Antônio Renato?
Certo. Tem tem como fazer sim. tava
fazendo, mas eu parei de fazer porque é
muito trabalhoso. Eu tava sem tempo.
Vi um vídeo que está tudo contaminado no
Brasil, que o café estaria também. Qual
a probabilidade que eles usam para
misturar no bebida etanol e no café
carne e leite? E qual alimento é mais
perigoso?
Eu não sei se eu entendi essa pergunta
um pouco esquisita.
O que que eles usam pro café?
Etanol no café. Não, não tem. Não estão
colocando etanol no café. Tão colocando
etanol. Etanol é é o álcool normal, tá?
Eles estão colocando metanol no álcool
normal. O a resto eu achei confusa a
pergunta. Antônio.
Confuso a pergunta.
Davi Tafó me deu o que você recomenda.
Como assim? Tem pega um Davita. Todos os
dois. Todos eles são bons, tá?
Todos eles são bons.
Vem, vamos ver que que vocês falaram ao
vivo aqui.
Gostaria de saber de como tomar
berberine.
Se for berberina normal, é 500 mg, duas
a três vezes ao dia. Se for bioberon,
que é um beberin de alta absorção, é 150
a 200 mg, duas a três vezes ao dia.
Tem tomar oxibil toda vez que comer.
Por que você tá falando de oxibil? Ah,
não tem vesícula, tá?
Não, é só os alimentos mais gordurosos.
Você precisa tomar o oxibid.
Que que tem o fosfato? Não entendi. Len
a fosfatil colina, você pode tomar ela
junto com algum alimento poduroso
também.
Isso aqui é muito difícil de controlar,
viu, Rafael? LPA tem um protocolo que
envolve
exicodinatinos vitamina C em altas
doses. Também tem vários aminoácidos
desse protocolo, protocolo bem extenso
que dá uma reduzida leve no LPA.
Existia uma fundação americana chamado
LPA Foundation, que infelizmente ela
faliu na pandemia. Então tem
pouquíssimas coisas que baixam.
Eu tenho um protocolo para isso que é
bem complicado.
Onde comprar os magnésios em boas lojas
que vendem produtos naturais? Pode
comprar na cirúrgica bergamoto.com.br.
Per,
deixa eu colocar aqui na tela para vocês
aqui.
Tá bom. Isso é um bom lugar para comprar
o magnésio. E tem vários blends de
magnésio no mercado, tá?
Tem vários.
É, eh, deixa eu pegar isso aqui
e colocar ele.
A, tem outro jeito de mostrar isso aqui.
Pera aí.
Ã, banners, né? Acho que é isso mesmo.
Banners.
Cirúrgica.
Bergamota.
br.
Pronto. Deixa eu ver se eu consigo
mostrar ao mesmo tempo com os
comentários aqui.
P pa pá. Cadê
sim aí tomaria essa combinação de rosto
bastantina embaixo dos que eu comentei
durante o vídeo, tá? Com bergavite, né,
que é o extrato bergamota.
E também o exeninato noitol
e também a berberina
que baixo temes a berberina.
Boa sorte, irmã.
Queria saber como funciona a dinâmica
das respostas.
A dinâmica, as pessoas perguntam, eu
respondo. Essa que é a dinâmica.
É melhor a gente dar sempre ênfase ao
documento, né, Rafael? Tá. Quando dá
tempo, a gente responde as perguntas ao
vivo também. Essa que é a dinâmica, tá?
A gente dá ênfase a aos documentos que a
gente manda um dia antes, na
segunda-feira. Boa noite, Dra. Ana.
A minha opinião sobre vitaminas no
complexo B, todas ou somente B12? É
melhor tomar todas, tá? por via das
dúvidas, se você não tiver como fazer os
exames.
Isso aqui é o ômega3 que eu tinha
mostrado.
Ah, eu já respondi isso aqui na outra
live, Eliseu.
Eu, particularmente, eu não vou fazer
musculação com estômago cheio. Eu espero
pelo menos 4 horas para poder fazer,
porque eu me sinto mal, tenho refluxo,
tá? Tá? Então eu só se for uma refeição
bem pequena, aí você poderia fazer meia
hora antes da atividade.
Suplemento GH. Que que é isso?
Não sei se tá querendo dizer que
suplemento GH. Eliseu GH é um hormônio,
né? Ele não se liga ao receptor de
testosterona, ele se liga ao receptor
GF1, tá?
Não é o tostano não
tem que ter mais concentração de EPA ou
de Dia. Quando é coração, né, para para
prevenir problemas de de coração ou
problemas cardiovasculares, é ter maior
de EPA. Se for memória intenção tem que
ser maior em DHA.
Eu não trabalho com terapias quânticas.
dizer, eu prefiro não me manifestar
sobre isso.
Qual é o perigo de café estar misturado
e manipulado? Depende do que misturou.
Se for só
cevada, coisas assim, não vai ter nenhum
perigo. Só vai ser um café de baixa
qualidade, né?
Agora, se for um café totalmente
adulterado, o perigo vai ser muito
maior.
Pangastrite, eu recomendaria aloe vera,
zincarnosina, glutamina,
tá? E licor TGL, tá? Eu recomendaria
essas coisas. Bem, pessoal, já temos
mais de uma hora de live, tá? Estão
respondendo o nosso amigo novo aí, o
André.
Eh, a gente responde primeiro sempre o
documento, desculpa, Rafael, não é
André, não. A gente sempre responde
primeiro documento, tá? Da prioridade e
quando dá tempo a gente discute alguns
artigos, tá? Eh, quando não tem tanta
pergunta, mas como tem muita pergunta
hoje, a gente não conseguiu discutir
artigo.
Beleza, pessoal? Muito obrigado aí pela
presença de vocês.
Responder essa última aqui. Beberina
alfa alipoico para melhorar resistência
insulínica.
Os dois. A resposta simples é os dois,
tá? Eu gravei um vídeo recente sobre
isso. Dá uma olhada lá.
Bem, pessoal, muito obrigado pela
presença de vocês. Um grande abraço e
até a próxima semana.